ديسكو
من القنابل النوويه التي تبيد ملايين
البشر الى قنابل كهرومغناطيسيه تعطل جميع
الاجهزه الالكترونيه والكهربائيه
تسعى روسيا التي هددت مرارا وتكرارا
باستخدام السلاح النووي الى اعتماد هذه
الاسلحه الكهرومغناطيسيه في ضرباتها على
كيف
خصوصا وانها تستطيع استخدامها دون ان
تخاطر باي تصعيد من الدول الغربيه
فهذه الاسلحه رغم انها لا تقصف المباني
ولا تقتل المدنيين الا انها لا تقل خطوره
عن الاسلحه النوويه
لانها قد تعطل جميع المعدات الدفاعيه التي
نشرها حلفاء النيه في اوكرانيا التي تعتمد
على اجهزه الراديو ونظام تحديد المواقع
العالمي والطائرات بدون طيار
وحدات الروسيه في اوكرانيا تحمل احد اخطر
هذه الاسلحه الكهرومغناطيسيه
وهو سلاح النبض الكهرومغناطيسي الذي
ستعتمد عليه في تعطيل البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه لاوكرانيا بحسب تقرير نشرات صحيفه
التايمز
موسكو عملت فيما مضى على تطوير هذه
المدافع التي تطلق هذه النبضات
الكهرومغناطيسيه في الجوه بزياده تصل الى
10 كيلومترات بعد سلسله من الاختبارات
خلال الصيف
ضربته هذا السلاح يتم تنفيذها باستخدام
تفجير منخفض القوه في الفضاء لانشاء نبضه
كهرومغناطيسيه تدمر الاجهزه الالكترونيه
غير المحميه
كما ان حجم الاستهداف فيه يتناسب مع مدى
ارتفاع النبضه في الجو اما فيما يتعلق
بالقوه التدميريه لهذه القنبله
الكهرومغناطيسيه فيكمل في مدى تاثيرها
والذي ينتشر في نطاق واسع خلال جزء من
الثانيه وبصوره غير مرئيه
وبسبب هذا الاثر المرئي الضئيل تصعب معرفه
ما اذا كان قد تم استخدامها بالفعل في هذه
الحرب
الاثار الكارثيه الاستعمال هذا السلاح من
الصعب احتوائها وقد تتاثر بسببها البنيه
التحتيه للدول المجاوره بما في ذلك دول
اعضاء بحلف شمال الاطلسي سلطان العربيه